it's great to be joined today by Sergei
Ryabkov element they're working on a
very very interesting project related to
ecommerce infrastructure and the
blockchain so I think Sergei the the
best place to start is what's the
problem that exists right now in
e-commerce that you're trying to solve
yeah you know the commerce market was
established in 1990s and there are lots
of different players there a huge like
Amazon and Alibaba and lots of small and
medium players there but there is lots
of problems there challenges first of
all there is no standard in
classification of goods and in this case
you know we can't compare the same goods
in Alibaba and Amazon and all other
online stores so we need to find every
goods in different online stores or
marketplaces and can't compare them by
price by delivery options etc the second
problem we usually don't know if we by
the online store the fake product or the
original it's a huge problem because
nobody can track the real path of goods
and in our case we create something like
a database of products of ownership of
products so you can see in time when
some some company bought this product
from another company from manufacturer
from distributor and you can track all
the paths here and also we create a
standard classification that can be used
by all players and in this case you can
find the same goods in all marketplaces
and online stores this is fascinating to
me so I want to go into a couple
different things that I think are really
interesting number one our American
audience may not understand this problem
of counterfeit goods this is actually a
problem that does exist in the United
States but it's much smaller in the
United States and it is
other countries can you talk about that
a little bit when you say someone can't
tell if they're buying the real product
or a counterfeit this is this is a major
problem in many parts of the world isn't
it a of course mostly in Russia in Asia
in Africa in lots of countries where you
you can't be sure that it's an original
product so it's lots of fakes here and
lots of products are very very similar
similar to their regions but when you
body them you don't have a guarantee you
have a rose quality and so on so when we
think about blockchain one of the things
blockchain is really good for even if
you don't have a deep understanding of
blockchain is that you can sort of track
the path of ownership of either a
digital good or even increasingly of
physical goods that sounds really great
but one question I have is can't you
just spoof the blockchain and it's proof
of ownership in other words the idea
would be blockchain would allow us to
see how did the product get to the last
person or retailer that you are buying
it from and that way we can work
backwards and see is this actually a
product from the brand name manufacturer
or is it a fake product isn't it
possible that someone could fake the
prior ownership through the blockchain
or is that exactly what blockchain
prevents you see in our case we work
with the stock inventory of all players
distributors manufacturers and we have
already a partnership with the CP
hybrids it's you just year P system in
the world used by a lots of huge
retailers and in this case we integrate
with them and you will see the real
process we have two parts that can prove
that the sale was really what was the
real sale because you have one part for
example distributor the other part has
and if they both proof that retailer
bought this product from distributor
then you will see this transaction here
and it would be a very huge problem to
change it because no in this case it's a
lots of about trust in this system of
course you will see their trust of all
players which joined this system and
it's very very hard to to change some
something here that's sort of inherent
to the structure of the blockchain right
I mean I think that's the idea when you
have the decentralized Authority where
the record is not controlled by any one
person that's sort of what prevents
someone from going back and changing
what the prior record is in a way I mean
it's sort of inherent to the structure
yeah I'm curious about some people might
here is talking and they would say well
but hold on a second can't you compare
products from different ecommerce
platforms using something like Google
Shopping you go to Google Shopping and
you type in a product and it shows you
here's what it costs on Amazon and
here's what it costs on BH photo/video
etc why is that not actually a solution
to the problem you identify first of all
when you go to for example Google
Shopping it's a marketplace it can use
our system when you enter something like
the name of the product you will see
lots of same products they are not
matched to one cart and usually it
doesn't doesn't know it's some
attributes for example you can't you can
enter iPhone 7 but you can't enter that
iPhone 7 black color and 128 gigabytes
and you can't choose the exit product
and to compare it at all online stores
the second thing that Google Shopping
and all other players here are
marketplaces that means that retailers
put information there and
pay for traffic and in this case you
know there are lots of lots of retailers
that don't use marketplaces because they
have very low prices very low margin and
they can't allow to themselves to use
the marketplaces because because they
need to pay for this traffic so mostly
you will find sometimes biggest online
stores but for example you can try to
find many early something something that
is available at Alibaba and Amazon
together and try to find it at Google
Shopping I am sure you will not find by
the one name the same product in all
these in these two retailers that's kind
of your problem in e-commerce isn't it
that you've got some places that are
using UPC codes for example node which
which graphically are represented as
barcodes on products you've got EAN
codes there's not sort of a uniform
standard that's used for a lot of
products and it seems like that's what
allows counterfeiters to sometimes take
advantage of that situation yeah it's
true because in all countries we use
different barcodes and it's a real
situation when you can see very
different kinds of products with the
same barcodes not even in different
countries but for example in foods
industry you will you can go to
different local retailers and see for
example cookies in one one shop with one
barcode and then the other shop it will
be the tomato with these probably be the
same barcode it seems like this is
particularly important in the developing
world right I mean in other words in
places where there is less access to
some world products and that could be a
result of like political and trade
considerations it could be dissolved the
result of economic situations it seems
that they're standardizing product
identification would sort of have the
most benefit right yeah interesting do
you think that this is the direction
that e-commerce is going more broadly
like in other words can you Eve
include the tracking and delivery and
shipping sort of elements of the
point-of-sale all the way from
manufacturer all the way to the end user
on the blockchain like you think that's
the future here yeah I'm sure that's its
few chips here because right now for
example in our case we track this the as
I already told the ownership of goods
but also we are going to partnership
with some block chains that track the
supply chain
mostly logistics with different chips
and you know it's mostly most about
hardware and in this case we can track
the ownership and the logistics when
these goods moving from one point to
another and together all this
information will help everyone to know
anything about any product talk to me
about the ICL what will the token do and
where are you in the process of the IC
oh yeah our talking is utility talking
in the system so retailers can use it to
get information from our blockchain and
to edit there it's they will pay only
the Commish transaction Commission's
here and usual people can also get
rewards for example for teaching our
machine learning algorithms that I used
to match the different names of the same
Goods so it's the talking that is using
like something like internal currency in
this system and we already started I see
oh they go and already got a soft cap
ten thousand either and our hard cap it
is thirty thousand and we have a month
to get it what's your timeline for the
full deployment of the platform on the
blockchain we are going to start the
test net in six months and till the end
of this year we are going to have the
full blockchain working with masternodes
and so i want to go back to what you
said about the utility of the token
someone is going to help your system
sort of link between two products that
might exist in different countries with
different UPC codes or with a UPC code
and an EIN code people who help your
system learn that these two products
might be the same product that would be
a way in which they would earn the token
as a reward is that correct yes it's
correct and what other uses will the
token have in addition to that we see
that as soon as different stores and
marketplaces will use our blockchain to
fill in their information about goods in
their stores in this case they can give
for example some sales discounts or even
sell the products for 100% of the price
for these stockings used by these people
who are awarded it and that's the way
how these tokens can be can make a
circulation when people can have had a
like a profit for that job and then pay
with them to get discounts or even the
whole goods and after that retailers who
got these stockings from these people
they can use them again to get more
information from the system what's the
advantage to the individual retailer
including like in a developing country
of working with the elements blockchain
like what can they do what advantage
exists if you're just like a small
electronic store in Europe for example
yeah you see when you start online store
the first the first thing that you need
to do after the starting the website you
need to feel it you need to add lots of
lots of information about goods and most
of this information is usual attributes
pictures etc and in this case for
example if you are going to sell only 10
goods it's it's not a problem but as
soon as you sell something as you said
for example elect
there are thousands of goods that you
can sell and you should spend lots of
time just to create these goods in your
online store because usually from
distributors you just get an excel file
without any information it could be just
a code and the price and quantity and
nothing else and you should create all
these beautiful pictures and attributes
and all this information texts and in
this case it's a huge problem because
it's lots of time to add new products
it's also usually lots of mistakes when
people just entering this information
manually and of course it's a problem
when you want to add the information
from your store - for example
marketplaces like Google Shopping now
even Amazon you need to know the codes
for UPC OEM or maybe you need to add the
special format of the name here and you
just need to change it every every time
just to get more traffic in the lower
case when they use element they just can
start the website and from our API get
all the information about goods standard
information it's you know pick all
pictures all attributes all codes or
different types of names from different
marketplaces and they can get it in a
few clicks and start selling absolutely
fascinating I think that this is in the
u.s. sometimes we don't understand what
things are like when it comes to a lot
of these products in other countries and
understanding that really sort of
exposes the utility of this which is
significant we've been speaking with the
CEO of element Sergei Ryabkov at element
dot IO Sergei thank you so much for
talking to me about this - thank you